confidence the prime minister can afford
to live in his own little world his own
little britain but people have to live
with the reality of a failing
westminster system a cost of living
crisis worse in the uk than any other g7
country an inflation rate double that of
france
the second worst economic growth
forecast in the g20 next to only
sanctioned russia and now a threat of
e-trade war with our european friends
triggered by a law-breaking prime
minister that is not a vision for the
future of scotland our nation is big
enough rich enough and smart enough
isn't it the case prime minister that
scotland simply can't afford to remain
trapped in the failing westminster
system
mr speaker stop the world scotland wants
to get on
minister
mr speaker i think that uh the the
figures speak for themselves the uk has
uh record numbers of people in uh
payroll employment that's a that's an
astounding thing uh when you consider
where we were during the pandemic that
was because of the uk working well
together as he will remember with the
vaccine rollout with the testing which
scotland and the rest of the country
cooperated brilliantly and uh mr speaker
he talks about a trade war he talks
about it he talks about a a trade war
what could be more foolish mr speaker
than a project that actually envisages
trade barriers within parts of the
united kingdom that's what we're trying
to break down great